نعم ، تعال إلى vinod no Country Heavy ما هذا
قال يا أيضا فترة أسبوع مع كمال الرخيص
أو شخص موضعي لا يسأل عن الجوارب رجل
الحرب تعكس ديريستوديو يونس و
طلاء الخشب jastram
بلد في
[موسيقى]
الحائط
يتحول اللون الأرجواني إلى اللون الأرجواني
[موسيقى]
حسن
يستحم فريق مؤسسة الحصان الأساسي
الطاقة ليست فكرة حسناً دعني أرى
ابحث عن ساق
إذا كان Play الآن متصلًا بـ Astra
سيحتاج القارئ لمواصلة الروح
اغفر لي معظم السيطرة على هذا العمل
[موسيقى]
بينهم في اسطنبول
هذا شائع
إنشاء مركز التنسيق
في البداية ، لا يخرج العميل من الأرائك.
السيطرة على السفن ، وكذلك
القهوة هنا تقريب جيد
السفن لضمان سلامة طرقها.
العديد من العروض ، بما في ذلك توفير
كوناكلي مصطفى تأثر بهذا في وقت لاحق
نرى هنا مجانًا ونرى أن هذا
الصور بعد حل المشكلة
هنا يأمل في إنجازه بطريقة ما
سنحاول أن نختتم بهذا
بمعنى الأسبوع المقبل أحزاب أوكرانيا
وتكرار هذه الأرقام في تركيا
هل يتحدث السوق الإجمالي؟